vous venez de les découvrir dans ce film
d'Orient Tiffany Sandra et les autres
perdus dans leur choix d'orientation
sans formation sans emploi ils ont
poussé la porte d'une mission locale
alsacienne pour intégrer un dispositif
proposé par l'État et espérer ainsi
mieux affronter un monde du travail
qu'ils ont le plus grand mal à
appréhender qui sont ces jeunes ruraux
au bord de l'oubli et de la précarité
quelles perspective vous leur offrir
pour espérer les tirer de l'ornière nous
allons en débattre maintenant avec mes
invités présents aujourd'hui sur ce
plateau de débat doc avec pour commencer
celui qui a réalisé ce documentaire que
nous venons de voir Ilan Teboul
bienvenue à vous Ilan Touboul merci vous
avez donc réalisé ce film entendez-vous
dans nos campagnes dont nous allons
reparler ensemble reparler de ces
moments c'est longs moments que vous
avez passé avec ces jeunes durant ce
tournage et non seulement ces jeunes du
côté de Molsheim en Alsace mais aussi de
et celle qui sont conseillées de ces
missions locales et qui aident ces
jeunes justement à insérer enfin le
milieu professionnel et avec nous
également Christine clorette Le Nabour
bienvenue à vous vous êtes député la
République en marche d'Ille-et-Vilaine
vice-président de l'un ml l'Union
nationale des missions locales justement
présidente de la Mission Locale de Vitré
autrement dit si on peut utiliser cette
expression vous avez les mains dans le
Cambri avec ces jeunes et ceux depuis
maintenant plusieurs années notamment du
côté de Vitré votre est dans votre
région vous êtes également membre de la
commission des affaires sociales de
l'Assemblée nationale et puis également
avec nous en webcam cette fois Benoît
cocard bienvenue à vous
bonjour vous êtes sociologue à
l'Institut national de la recherche
agronomique l'INRA vous travaillez
depuis maintenant plusieurs années sur
les milieux ruraux et les classes
populaires et vous êtes l'auteur entre
autres de ceux qui restent faire sa vie
dans les campagnes en déclin un ouvrage
publié aux éditions de La Découverte
merci beaucoup à vous d'être avec nous
également pour cette émission et après
ce documentaire que vous avez donc
réalisé pourquoi avoir choisi de tourner
ce sujet en Alsace à Molsheim alors à
l'origine c'est la fiction qui m'amène
au documentaire au départ j'écrivais un
scénario de fiction et qui s'intéressait
à la notion de frontière on le rappelle
dans le film parce que la situation
sanitaire m'a un peu empêché de le
traiter mais la frontière est très
proche sont des jeunes frontaliers et
donc je suis d'abord parti en 2016 pour
rencontrer des jeunes
grâce à des associations une puis deux
puis trois et à l'origine votre sujet ce
sont les jeunes frontaliers j'imagine
c'est comme ça que vous nous absolument
et vous en arrivez à nous faire ce film
sur sur ces jeunes dans cette mission à
Molsheim pourquoi ben en fait déjà ça a
été grâce à l'intervention de Carmen
Valentin qui est la directrice adjoint
je crois de la Mission locale
qui m'a donné accès à un peu plus que
d'autres associations elle m'a proposé
de participer à
un atelier des jeunes de garanties
jeunes commençaient leur atelier là tout
de suite je commençais à m'intéresser à
la notion de ruralité parce que je la
campagne dans laquelle j'étais ne
ressemblait pas aux campagnes mais vous
en venez de la campagne moi pas du tout
pas du tout non non pas du tout non non
dans le 93 et il y avait quand même
certaines similitudes
dans l'approche que j'avais les mots que
j'entendais dans la bouche de ces jeunes
avec des justement des jeunes du 93 vous
souvenez de ce qui vous a le plus frappé
lorsque vous avez pour la première fois
rencontrer cette ces jeunes dans cette
mission locale
il y a pas mal de choses mais on va dire
que je suis entré dans la salle de
classe de l'atelier collectif donné par
Chantal qu'on voit dans le documentaire
qui est aussi professeur donc de théâtre
pour ces jeunes et Chantal donc moi je
suis là comme une petite souris
j'assiste et elle se sent obligé de
voilà de signifier ma présence assez
jeune et lundi voilà on a un réalisateur
aujourd'hui qui est là il réfléchit sur
les thèmes de sur la sur le thème de la
ruralité et leur dit est-ce que vous
savez ce que c'est que la réalité et la
plupart de ces jeunes
ont répondu la ruralité c'est la ville
la ruralité c'est les blocs la réalité
c'est les cités
donc au-delà de de leur méconnaissance
il ne se s'identifiez pas eux-mêmes
comme des jeunes ruraux et je crois que
là le film a commencé pour moi
on va regarder un extrait de ce film
c'est le tout début ce sont ces jeunes
qui arrivent et qui se présentent même
qui vous présente en réalité leur
parcours on les réécoute puis on en
parle bien sûr juste après
j'ai travaillé dans le domaine de la
restauration McDonald's pendant un an et
demi et avant ça j'ai travaillé à la
Halle aux chaussures en tant que
conseillère de vente et puis je me suis
dirigée vers un
BTS Comptabilité et au bout de quelques
mois ben j'ai démissionné parce que ça
me plaisait pas
et donc après je me suis dirigée vers la
Mission Locale parce que j'étais perdue
dans mon choix de d'orientation jusqu'à
qui a besoin justement d'avoir
qu'on me pousse qu'on me qu'on m'aide
tout simplement et du coup bah la fac
c'est pas du tout ça j'ai fait ce bac
parce que j'avais un autre affaire en
fait je voulais me rentrer dans une
branche plus générale dans les scènes
général mais c'était pas possible mon
niveau les profs m'ont dit de pas faire
ça et de vous montrer plus vers les
initi pro donc je les ai écoutés quoi
il y a pas grand chose à dire sur ça
parce que j'ai arrêté l'école en
troisième qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire de
la typologie des jeunes auxquels nous
avons affaire dans ce documentaire y
a-t-il seulement une typologie à un peu
général à en sortir qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire à qui a-t-on à faire
réellement
déjà on peut on peut dire merci en fait
à ce documentaire de mettre le doigt sur
une réalité objective en fait les jeunes
ruraux sont dans leur grande majorité
des enfants issus des ce qu'on appelle
les catégories populaires c'est
davantage des enfants doux et d'employés
bien davantage qu'en ville et donc
beaucoup moins
issus des catégories des favorisés et
quelque chose auquel peut-être une
réalité à laquelle on pense pas quand on
parle de milieu rurales mais il y a une
proportion en fait très très importante
de jeunes qui sont sans emploi et sans
diplôme qui ont quitté l'école très tôt
dans des proportions qui sont
comparables monsieur Teboul parlait du
93 justement à celle de la
Seine-Saint-Denis donc on retrouve des
problématiques sociales qui sont qui
sont relativement comparables même si
elles ne sont pas équivalentes parce que
elle se développe pas dans les mêmes
territoires il y a pas les mêmes
opportunités de travail c'est pas
exactement les mêmes jeunesses mais en
tout cas voilà c'est cette difficulté là
d'insertion professionnelle de rapport à
la mobilité
des espèces d'espérance en qui est
complètement déjà déchu à l'âge de 15
ans ça reflète la réalité de toute une
partie de la jeunesse rurale et c'est
important je pense de dire ça
aujourd'hui parce que les représentation
qu'on peut avoir de la campagne ce
serait avant tout qu'elle serait peuplée
d'agriculteurs faut rappeler que les
actifs agricoles même en milieu rural ça
représente 4 à 5 % de la population
active et que par exemple les ouvriers
c'est 32 entre 32 et 35 % que les
employés 50% donc ces jeunes là se
destinent plutôt à ce type de métier
plutôt qu'à l'agriculture qui
aujourd'hui emploie peu de personnes
vous tirez les mêmes conclusions vous
voulez rajouter quelque chose concernant
ces jeunes que vous avez côtoyés
avez-vous des informations un peu plus
précises sur la typologie de de ces
jeunes auxquels nous avons à faire dans
le film alors déjà je voulais remercier
Ilan Teboul parce que pour deux raisons
la première c'est d'abord c'est un
documentaire touchant qu'il reflète la
diversité des parcours parce que on voit
quand même que il il y a des des raisons
communes en fait à leur échec scolaire à
leur manque de confiance à leur
problématiques d'insertion
dans la vie professionnelle mais il y a
des parcours quand même très très variés
et je vous rejoins complètement on a
c'est même problématiques dans les
quartiers politiques de la ville on
n'apporte pas peut-être pas les mêmes
réponses mais en tous les cas on a des
problématiques
identiques de mobilité
de mobilité physique mais de mobilité
dans la tête quand on sait que un jeune
quelquefois son horizon c'est le
quartier c'est sa commune et ça ne va
pas plus loin dans les jeunes ruraux ont
des spécificités on a parlé de mobilité
à l'instant avec Benoît cocard par
exemple ce sont des vrais problèmes de
terrain et puis peut-être et ça ressort
d'un certain nombre d'études il y a
moins d'ambition il y aurait moins
d'ambition alors tout dépend de ce qu'on
met sous le chapitre ambition installé
subjectif de la part de ces à comparer
aux jeunes urbains dans le parcours
scolaire notamment c'est une réalité
aussi oui mais ça c'est exactement la
même problématique dans les quartiers
souvent on
il y a ce manque de perspective ce
manque de de foi en l'avenir et ça je
pense que c'est parce qu'il y a des des
freins périphériques qui sont arrivés
très tôt des des problèmes familiaux des
problèmes de violence des problèmes
d'échec scolaires mais bon ça en découle
et puis cette se renfermement sur soi et
c'est certainement encore plus compliqué
en milieu rural puisque et bien là vous
avez l'isolement qui se rajoute à tout
un tas de de freins par ailleurs vous
parlez de des milieux sociaux et Dieu
sait s'ils sont importants la comprit
dans ce documentaire qui on va écouter
un deuxième extrait de votre film qui
illustre parfaitement bien la difficulté
à cerner les missions sociaux dans son
tissu ces jeunes
et demi qui au début était très gentille
attentif il était pas du tout violent et
au fur et à mesure
du coup voilà
même si vous avez un copain si la
mauvaise alcool ou autre
protégez-vous avant que ça
ils peuvent vous tuer tu m'excuses mais
quand même comme on dit l'amour est
aveugle malgré ce qui nous fait je suis
désolé si je me ma peur avec toi je suis
aussi subi à peu près la même chose mais
bon moi je vous sais pas ce que je
voulais en parler j'ai vu l'image mais
je m'en parlais assis je suis désolé je
suis bien violée à 5 ans donc je sais ce
que tu subis donc voilà avec une jeune
femme victime de violences conjugales
d'une part et une autre victime de
violence sexuelles ça sont des
problématiques
propres à votre avis à cette population
telle que vous avez pu l'observer les
origines sociales les violences sociales
dont elles ont été victimes avant
d'arriver dans ces missions locales
expliquerait pour beaucoup le décrochage
qui est assez bien illustré dans votre
documentaire aussi de ces jeunes
expliquer en partie
l'échec aussi du premier on va dire de
la première expérience professionnelle
déjà on en a pas parlé c'est essentiel
c'est à dire que la première expérience
professionnelle est souvent la première
fois qu'un jeune va se retrouver dans le
monde des adultes c'est pas rien pour
lui et si cette expérience se passe mal
il se met en rupture avec ce monde des
adultes lui qui est déjà dans une phase
de passage quand on a entre 17 et 20 ans
voilà on est encore un peu un enfant et
pas vraiment on est un jeune adulte on
sait plus on sait pas vraiment où on est
et souvent ces premières expériences
entérinent l'idée qu'il est plus simple
de rester un enfant et c'est souvent des
jeunes adultes marqués par quelque chose
qui est lors de l'enfance qui arrive là
et je suis pas étonné que c'est paroles
ce genre de c'est retour d'expérience là
c'est parole qu'il se libèrent ici
c'est pas étonnant c'est parce que
justement le dispositif en tout cas
celui-ci et ces jeunes en particulier
convoque tout ce qui est de l'ordre de
l'enfance et des blessures du passé à
travers le prisme du travail c'est ça
qui est assez étonnant Christine Florac
vous leur âgée je voulais réagir parce
que on travaille beaucoup et trop
souvent seulement sur l'employabilité
des jeunes et je vous rejoins
complètement c'est que on doit
travailler aussi sur l'employeur
habilité des entreprises parce que le
premier le premier accueil dans une
entreprise et essentielle et que souvent
effectivement ces jeunes sont marqués
par un premier accueil Qui est qui est
compliqué qui a été compliqué avec le
patron et bien il y a il y a du coup
cette défiance dans le milieu de
l'entreprise il faut remobiliser le
jeûne
il faut partir de ce repartir de son
potentiel lui dire que qu'il a plein de
choses à valoriser de le rendre acteur
en fait de son parcours et ça c'est tout
le travail des conseillers en insertion
des missions locales
la mission de ces fameuses missions
locales c'est d'insérer ou de réinsérer
ces jeunes dans le milieu professionnel
mais de quel niveau d'études partent-ils
ces jeunes il semble qu'il quitte
davantage le milieu scolaire plutôt que
les autres par exemple
qui disait un niveau de
scolarité moindre moins d'études
supérieures moins de diplômes supérieurs
comment est-ce qu'on explique ça du côté
des jeunes ruraux qui nous concernent
aujourd'hui
scolaires plus restreints et ils ont des
vœux de moins longues études en fait que
leurs homologues
urbains un niveau social égal donc
effectivement ils viennent souvent de
famille où les parents n'ont pas fait
d'études mais eux-mêmes déjà ils ne se
projettent peu vers le milieu étudiant
ça s'explique aussi parce qu'en milieu
rural il y a peu d'emplois relativement
moins d'emplois en fait qui demandent
des qualifications des diplômes du
supérieur moi j'ai pu suivre dans mes
recherches des jeunes femmes qui étaient
partis ben voilà étudier dans une grande
ville universitaire qui est située à
1h30 2h de route elles veulent revenir
dans la campagne de laquelle elles sont
originaires là où elles ont leurs
familles leurs proches leurs bandes de
potes etc et elle n'y arrive pas et elle
me dit souvent ben voilà si je veux
rentrer il va falloir que je fasse une
croix sur mon diplôme et que je fasse
caissière donc je dévalorise
complètement le diplôme et on dit tout
le temps aux jeunes allez-y le diplôme
vous protège du chômage il vous protège
du chômage si vous l'investissez dans
les espaces urbains qui concentrent les
différents types de capitaux et les
métiers que l'on dit les plus qualifiés
et là où on se rend compte en fait que
ce dispositif à la fois il tient par la
grande application des différents
acteurs par toutes les personnes ils
mettent du coeur et notamment même les
jeunes qui participent et d'un autre
côté ils rencontrent en fait des
contraintes structurelles là dans le
précédent extrait on avait des
difficultés qui sont inhérentes à la
condition féminine en milieu rurale en
fait moi un endroit qui travaille
notamment sur le chômage des jeunes dans
beaucoup de Bourges des campagnes des
industrialisés le taux de chômage et
jeunes femmes il est le double voire le
triple de celui des jeunes hommes et ces
inégalités là sur le milieu du travail
on le retrouve moi je m'intéresse à la
vie intime la vie de couple à la vie
amicale on les retrouve dans ces sphères
là qu'on pourrait dire plus ou moins
protégé mais en fait quand vous formez
un couple entre un jeune homme qui a
déjà un emploi qui a 4 ou 5 ans de plus
que sa compagne et du coup la jeune
femme qui vient le rejoindre dans son
village qui habitait pas forcément là
avant parce qu'ils sont rencontrés en
boîte de nuit ou sur internet donc elle
peut être originaire de 50 km elle coupe
de sa famille elle se retrouve
dépendante de lui et en plus elle a pas
encore le permis de conduire elle a pas
de travail donc il peut y avoir des
formes de violence symboliques ou
physiques en fait qui sont corroborés
par ces inégalités structurelles là et
c'est là où le ou parfois le dispositif
en fait va se taper un peu la tête dans
le mur parce que malgré toutes les
implications il y a des contraintes
liées à là où on est et qui on est quel
de quelle ressources on dispose en fait
pour faire son parcours il y a une forme
parfois je trouve
dans les dispositifs de ce type de
relatifs violence dans le fait d'avoir
une injonction pour ces jeunes des
catégories populaires à avoir déjà un
projet professionnel alors même qu'ils
savent qu'ils prendront ce qui vient
parce que de d'emblée ils ont fait leur
vie ici ils entendent vivre et
travailler au pays mais ils savent que
les possibilités sont très limitées mais
on leur dit dès qu'ils ont 15 ans 14 ans
voire il faut que tu saches ce que tu
veux faire alors que les jeunes des
catégories les privilégiés on leur
laisse faire des années de sesures aller
en erasmuses etc jusqu'à 25 ans avant
vraiment de se stabiliser dans l'emploi
et là il y a vraiment quelque chose je
pense sur lequel il faudrait réfléchir
par rapport aux conditions de vie réelle
et aux possibilités réels de choix qu'on
sait jeunes en fait ils en ont pas
beaucoup des choix et l'un des bouts je
vous vois te Bull pardon je vous vois à
qui est-ce qui vient d'être dit moi ce
que j'ai envie de comprendre c'est je
reprends ce terme ambition sans qu'il
soit péjoratif quel est l'ambition de
ces jeunes que vous avez rencontré
est-ce que c'est de rester travailler
sur leur territoire est-ce que c'est
d'avoir accès à des études supérieures
via la première ville universitaire qui
se sur leur territoire et ce qui est une
vraie volonté d'ascension sociale chez
ces jeunes ou alors ce que l'avenir est
bouché et ce manque d'horizon que vous
avez évoqué tout à l'heure qui pose
véritablement un problème et sur lequel
il faut peut-être travailler alors
en fait ce qui est intéressant quand on
se fait un groupe c'est que on a comme
ça un panel de personnalité et dans ce
panel de personnalité il n'y a pas
vraiment de
tendance qui se dessine pour être très
franc alors que il y a aussi il y a
autant des jeunes femmes ce qui a
beaucoup de jeunes femmes dans ce groupe
là c'était comme ça ils étaient que
trois ou quatre garçons bon dans dans le
groupe que j'ai suivi
certaines aujourd'hui
beaucoup d'entre elles ça y est sont en
formation
on trouvait une voie en tout cas qui
leur plaît pour certaines une voix tout
court pour d'autres c'est vrai je voilà
et
leur territoire pour répondre à ma
question est-ce que la priorité c'est
d'abord de rester sur son territoire ou
est-ce qu'il maintenant il y a une
volonté un désir de franchir le pas
d'aller dans une grande ville et une
ville universitaire
c'est pas si clair que ça parce que moi
je les ai filmé à un moment où il
n'allait pas très bien sûr voilà donc
sur mes 100 perspective au moment où je
leur pose la question qu'est-ce que où
tu te vois plus tard ailleurs il y a pas
de doute mais après on va dire qu'ils
sont ils reprennent confiance en eux on
le voit avec la jeune Sandra absolument
qui a un parcours qui est assez
incroyable au début du documentaire
c'est un tout petit oiseau
elle est toute palote on a peur pour
elle et puis on la voit huit mois plus
tard c'est quelqu'un d'autre
sur ma question peut-être avez-vous vos
propres réponses quand je parlais
d'horizon tout à l'heure c'est le
sentiment
qu'ils ont de ne pas pouvoir aller plus
loin ceci dit encore une fois tout le
travail d'accompagnement qui est fait
par les conseillers en insertion c'est
justement de de partir des attentes des
besoins
de de prendre conscience aussi que le
parcours en amont il a été difficile et
qu'il faut remobiliser ces jeunes pour
pour qu'il s'inscrivent dans un dans un
une trajectoire et et ce qui est
intéressant dans cette garantie jeune
c'est qu'il se retrouve tous en
collectif et que il s'aperçoivent qu'ils
ne sont pas tout seuls à vivre ces
problématiques qu'elles soient les
problématiques de santé de mobilité de
logement de violence conjugales ou
familiales et que ça ça crée une
émulation
du travail collectif qu'on voit au début
du documentaire tout à fait qui va
peut-être pas correspondre d'ailleurs
d'emblée tout de suite à tous les jeunes
mais qui est important alors on est en
train de réfléchir à des garanties
jeunes un peu adaptées dans lesquelles
il y aurait plutôt des phases de
collectif
par moment sous forme d'atelier pour que
progressivement le jeûne s'habitue à ce
collectif ce que tout le monde ne rentre
pas dans le collectif il y a un jeune
d'ailleurs d'Orient je crois qui a
beaucoup de mal à d'abord d'emblée à
rentrer dans le collectif Benoît Coquard
je vous repose un peu la même question
mais est-ce que la motivation d'une
émancipation sociale d'une d'une
ascension sociale
peut jouer c'est ces jeunes ou est-ce
que c'est la motivation de d'abord
rester sur un territoire et de
participer à sa vie Locale de rester
parti prenante de l'activité économique
de son territoire qui prime chez ses
jeunes en fait il y a vraiment comme
disait monsieur Teboul des moments c'est
à dire que les adolescents que je
rencontrais ils me disait ici c'est mort
je me m'en aller vivement que j'ai le
permis il manque je parte tenter ma
chance ailleurs parce que j'ai le
sentiment d'être un peu grillé ici
notamment ceux qui avaient déjà un peu
ce qu'ils entendaient être une mauvaise
réputation c'est à dire qu'ils avaient
connu un petit peu le chômage il y avait
eu des fois des parcours qui étaient
jugés comme un petit peu déviants comme
par l'interconnaissance du village parce
que c'est ça grandir dans un village et
il y a une mémoire collective quand vous
avez mal commencé entre guillemets votre
vie professionnelle et même votre vie
sociale tout court mais on s'en rappelle
et on va vous catégoriser déjà donc il y
a des jeunes qui me disaient je peux
même pas par exemple proposer de faire
du travail au noir et des petits boulots
chez les gens parce que j'ai une
mauvaise réputation et je vais aller
tenter ma chance ailleurs pourquoi pas
il y avait l'Eldorado Suisse la
thématique de la frontière moi me parle
beaucoup parce que je travaille sur le
Grand Est il y a toujours cette espèce
d'espoir d'émancipation par l'argent en
fait il y a ceux qui veulent s'émanciper
par les études et les autres qui se
disent je vais aller m'enrichir même
sans diplôme ailleurs et bon évidemment
il y en a beaucoup qui qui se cassent
les dents là-dessus et c'est là où c'est
important quand on les récupère moi ça
fait 10 ans que je suis les mêmes
personnes quand on les récupère quelques
années après qui commence à avoir passé
25 ans bientôt la trentaine pour les
personnes que je suis elles ont des
stratégies concrètes de retour c'est à
dire qu'elles sont parties notamment les
jeunes femmes qui ont voulu être diplômé
etc mais elles essayent en fait de
revenir là où elles ont leurs familles
là où elles pensent que elles ont un
sens à leur vie ou et surtout parce que
la ville ne leur a pas forcément plus ou
j'avais beaucoup de discours sur le fait
de Paris plus jamais de la vie la grande
vie la grande ville plus jamais la vie
parce que des personnes on disait
personne te connaît personne te
reconnaît et il est vrai que si vous
comparez de profils équivalents par
exemple ceux d'un ouvrier en bâtiment
parce que moi j'ai eu le cas de
quelqu'un qui a travaillé en ville et à
la campagne faisait à la campagne on va
dire que tu as de l'ordre dans les mains
on te voit bosser concrètement le gamin
qui rentre en apprentissage à ce qui à
16 ans puis de deux ans plus tard ils
vont ils conduit le camion de la boîte
il a monté il a de l'autonomie dans la
petite entreprise il est très très
valorisé en fait et le même la même
personne qui vient par exemple des
quartiers populaires qui bossent en
intérim et qui reprend le RER pour aller
dormir à 30 km de là où il a travaillé
il ne sait pas du tout qu'est-ce qu'on a
pensé de lui et voilà c'est c'est des
formes de reconnaissance que permettent
le milieu rural ou qu'elle ces jeunes là
sont très attachés sans compter le fait
qu'ils ont gardé leurs amis qu'ils ont
des loisirs de des chevaux etc vous les
avez concentre ville donc ils y tiennent
en fait à ce style de Villa mais parfois
c'est impossible de l'accomplir et
Benoît que car vous nous parlez tout
particulièrement de cette jeunesse du
Grand Est ce que vous connaissez bien
puisque vous en venez du Grand Est c'est
un territoire que vous connaissez
particulièrement bien
et ces jeunes évidemment par ailleurs
vous parliez de Sandra tout à l'heure
Ilan teboule on va la réécouter
elle est caissière et elle a obtenu le
permis de conduire
je suis hôtesse de caisse c'est parce
que je rêvais de faire depuis toute
petite ça c'est sûr mais ça va comme
premier travail à Pierre
la première semaine c'était compliqué
j'avais peur je stressé avant d'y aller
forcément parce que c'est quelque chose
qu'on connaît pas donc peur d'aller dans
l'inconnu quoi merci à vous aussi
[Musique]
et c'était cool ça a changé ma vie ça
j'ai ma voiture aussi vu que j'ai un
travail je peux mettre l'essence quand
je veux aussi c'est ce qu'il me fallait
en fait d'être plus autonome comme ça
[Musique]
Sandra elle a donc trouvé un travail de
caissière et elle a obtenu le permis de
conduire et je voulais en venir sur un
problème qu'on a évoqué au début de
cette émission c'est la mobilité de ces
jeunes alors mobilité physique et puis
peut-être mobilité psychologique
c'est-à-dire cette capacité justement à
la mobilité qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire l'ascendant elle est
heureuse elle a retrouvé et enfin elle
peut c'est le permis le grand c'est le
permis de conduire c'est le permis de
conduire pour beaucoup de jeunes des
régions dont nous parlons là
complètement il faut quand même donc je
suis en voiture avec elle à ce moment-là
je la suis en train de la filmer on est
parti de chez elle à oberlard donc qui
est à environ 40 à 50 km de son emploi
autant vous dire que pour rentrer après
récupérer notre matériel notre voiture
on a mesuré des distances que ces gènes
sont obligés de parcourir pour
travailler déjà ça a été la première
chose donc si Sandra n'avait pas de
permis de conduire et quand elle n'avait
pas de permis elle était vraiment
éloignée de l'emploi donc là c'est la
première mais on voit une autre jeune
dans votre film qui se lève tous les
matins à 5 heures même dans une voiture
pour aller en formation à la Mission
Locale absolument on se rend compte de
cette difficulté quand même tout est
loin finalement pour ces jeunes aussi
l'accès au service public l'accès au
service de santé de formation ça vous a
frappé ça au moment où ça me frappé bien
sûr ça m'a frappé et ça m'a ça m'a
touché aussi beaucoup parce que autant
ils sont très fiers de là où ils
habitent je vais à grain delbruche donc
voir Tiffany dans les magnifiques
Hautmont voilà c'est vallonné c'était
très beau et
ils sont à la fois très fiers de vivre
là
et ils sont totalement bloqués là et
c'est très paradoxal en fait
sur ce la mobilité ça a l'air d'être une
des clés la mobilité pour ces jeunes la
mobilité je l'ai dit physique le permis
de conduire mais peut-être aussi cette
capacité à imaginer cette mobilité dans
leur parcours professionnel à l'avenir
complètement alors il y a plein de
dispositifs parce qu'on quand même qui
existent et qui sont à la main des
missions locales et qui permettent à la
fois de passer le permis il y a ce qu'on
appelle la conduite supervisée par
exemple en mission locale vous c'est à
dire que des bénévoles accompagnent les
jeunes pour remplacer les parents en
conduite accompagnée il y a aussi les
aides au permis ce sont des aides
financières et puis dernièrement et bien
il y a une nouvelle mesure qui est
arrivée avec des l'équipement de 24
missions locales alors sur 440 on n'y
est pas mais ça commence pour 24
missions locales il va y avoir des
simulateurs de conduite qui vont
permettre et bien d'accélérer le
processus de passage de permis c'est le
Graal vous l'avez dit il faut
je voulais juste revenir sur la ruralité
pour moi il y a les déruralité comme il
y a des jeunesses comme il y a des
profils différents et suivant si on est
dans le milieu rural mais tout près
d'une gare et avec la possibilité
d'aller vers la métropole ou d'aller
vers les villes c'est simple quand on
n'est pas du tout sur une voie de chemin
de fer ou de bus et bien il faut le
permis ça c'est c'est une une condition
sinequanone pour pouvoir aller vers en
formation pour pouvoir aller chercher un
emploi et pour pouvoir accéder à
l'emploi est-ce qu'on peut tirer un tant
soit peu un bilan de la garantie jeune
qui est évoqué évidemment dans ce film
ces jeunes sont là pour 12 mois en
l'occurrence
vous l'avez dit il y a 436 missions
locales en France
1,1 million de jeunes accompagnés par
ces missions locales avec un encadrement
composé d'environ 13500 professionnels
on les salue d'ailleurs au passage on en
a vu un certain nombre d'entre eux à
l'oeuvre
dans ce film est-ce qu'on peut tirer un
bilan de ce dispositif la garantie jeune
par exemple parce qu'il est tout de même
en place depuis 2013 j'imagine qu'on a
un peu de recul maintenant
quels sont les résultats de ce
dispositif à ce jour pour ces jeunes
alors il a été généralisé en 2015 il a
d'ailleurs été expérimenté ce coup-ci à
l'ouest puisque à Brest en Bretagne il a
été généralisé et on a vite vu que
c'était un dispositif qui marchait bien
alors la garantie jeune c'est un
dispositif d'accompagnement renforcé
avec un collectif de quatre à six
semaines et puis une un accompagnement
sur un an voir sur 18 mois on le
rappelle pas assez il y a quand même un
renouvellement possible
être formé dans le cadre de ces
garanties l'idée c'est quand même
d'essayer d'insérer le jeûne le plus
rapidement possible alors le recul c'est
que ça marche et d'ailleurs comme ça
marche et bien le l'exécutif a décidé de
de l'adapter de l'enrichir et de le
conforter vous voulez rajouter un mot
oui et quand même quelque chose dont on
ne parle pas qui est essentiel c'est
qu'il y a une allocation c'est à dire
que ces jeunes qui ont de moins de 25
ans touche 497 euros voilà et enfin ça
change la vie quand on a 18 ans ou 19
ans dans le cas de ces jeunes qu'on
n'avait pas toujours chez Papa Maman on
habite parce que on s'est un peu
brouillé avec eux et qu'on vit chez un
beau-frère ou chez quelqu'un et on n'a
pas rien pour vivre
il y a aussi un truc qu'il faut ajouter
c'est que le c'est un peu un hameçon
cette cette histoire et de la location
oui elle le dit il y en a peut-être qui
viennent que pour l'argent le dit dans
le documentaire et vous comprendrez
après et finalement moi je trouve ça pas
si mal Benoît coca votre avis votre
regard sur les dispositifs en place pour
aider les jeunes à s'en tirer et
notamment ce fameux dispositif la
garantie jeune dont on vient de parler à
l'instant et qui est très bien illustré
dans ce film
je pense que on voit des choses qu'on
connaissait déjà avec d'autres
dispositifs c'est qu'ils vont accélérer
en fait l'insertion des jeunes dans des
territoires qui s'y prêtaient déjà
plutôt bien je pense aux ruralité de
l'Ouest de la France ruralité proche des
grandes métropoles en fait qui sont déjà
très dynamiques où on a des niveaux de
vie qui sont comparables à ceux des
milieux urbains et bon il faut dire ce
qui est dans le grand est quand même des
impasses par rapport au fait d'être
mobile à des échelles ou ben en fait
l'emploi recule depuis des années 90 on
peut recule massivement de toute cette
France rurale et industrielle en fait
qui a largement laissé été laissé à
l'abandon et d'une mobilité voulue d'une
autonomie recherchée par ces jeunes là
moi quand je les récupère 5-6 ans après
on a une forme de contrainte ou comme
vous l'aviez dit très bien tout à
l'heure il me disait tout est loin et
ils étaient moi je les ai vu parmi les
premiers sur les barrages des gilets
jaunes à dire on ne fait que manger des
amandes parce que je prenais la journée
typique d'une jeune femme qui était
justement en emploi mais qui venait
d'avoir un enfant il me disait à l'école
a été déplacé à l'intercommunalité à 20
km la crèche a fermé il faut l'emmener
dans une maison d'assistante maternelle
à un autre 20 km et il y a plus de
supérette dans le village le soir donc
il faut aller au supermarché qui est
loin lui aussi et en plus je travaille à
mi-temps dans le secteur du service à la
personne qui emploie beaucoup de jeunes
femmes en milieu rurale et donc elle se
heurtait en fait à cette impossibilité
là ou moi je le disais mais tu peux
essayer de tenter ta chance dans le
bassin d'emploi d'à côté qui était un
petit peu plus médias mais là aussi on
est plusieurs dizaines de filles que je
connais par ailleurs a postuler au même
emploi donc on arrive sur des appâts qui
sont pas simplement liés à ce dispositif
là c'est à dire que ça renvoie au fait
que il y a des il y a des zones qu'on a
développé à un moment donné pour
certains secteurs de l'industrie
qu'aujourd'hui ne sont plus du tout
pourvu on essaye de les retraduire en
zone touristique mais ça va pas
forcément marcher donc ces jeunes là
vont se retrouver un petit peu pris dans
la crise de leur territoire à une chaîne
beaucoup plus vaste que le seul village
le seul Christine Correc 15 secondes pas
plus c'est tout l'enjeu de l'agenda
rural qui est mis en se passe depuis un
petit moment et qui est mis en place par
Joël Giraud ministre ruralité à la
ruralité c'est de faire en sorte que ces
territoires soient dynamiques pour que
une fois voilà qu'ils rentrent dans un
parcours d'insertion et là dans c'est
dans la garantie jeune qu'il puisse
avoir les services qui vont avec et
l'emploi qui va avec ce sera le mot de
la fin merci beaucoup Hélène Teboul pour
ce documentaire qui est venu illustrer
notre émission débadoc de ce jour merci
à tous les trois d'avoir participé à ce
débat doc consacré à la jeunesse
précarisée vivant en milieu rural vous
l'avez compris pour réagir à cette
émission rendez-vous sur hashtag de
Badoc sur Twitter et je vous donne
rendez-vous quant à moi à tous et à
toutes pour un prochain débat doc avec
bien sûr son documentaire et son débat à
bientôt
[Musique]